they actually did it they did it we
joked about them doing it and then
they did it we all joked about how the
democrats were going to pull a kavanagh
and accuse judge amy coney barrett of
sexual harassment during her supreme
court
nomination hearings we didn't think it
was going to actually happen right but
then
then they actually did it since you
became a legal adult have you ever
made unwanted requests for sexual favors
or committed any verbal
or physical harassment or assault of a
sexual nature
no senator hirono have you ever faced
discipline
or entered into a settlement related to
this kind of conduct
no senator there are many jokes to be
made here
i am going to refrain from making them
actually i guess the democrats
themselves are the joke because the
confirmation hearings only went downhill
from there
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from westin
who says the the worst thing about
klobuchar is her voice
it sounds like she's constantly on the
brink of tears
that's fair enough but it's still better
than cory booker
who constantly is in tears so at least
with clovia char you know there's just
maybe it's some something about the
vocal quality
but with booker my goodness gracious
spartacus was nearly crying tears of
rage the whole time and maybe a few
droplets popped out
we will get to him as well it was
a very bad day for democrats it did not
look
good at all look anything could change
they might have some big trick up their
sleeve today but it seemed as though
for most of the hearings the democrats
had just sort of
given up you know i i know that
we're all on eggshells here with these
supreme court nominations
this is the issue in the presidential
election at least for right now
and we thought that judge barrett was
going to have a close shave in there but
but she did not if you do want a close
shave however i would recommend you
check out
hairy razors harry's razors is
the best i've ever used okay i've i just
started using harry's
i'm gonna say about a month ago maybe a
month and a half ago
and i've tried a bunch of razor brands
all my these are the best
not even close they've just come out
with their sharpest blades ever
unlike some other razor companies they
are not charging you for their product
improvements harry's new sharper blades
are still as low as two dollars each
now if you're using some of the big
names that have been around for a long
time
you're probably paying significantly
more than that
for each razor how do they do it harry
zone's a german factory they've been
making razor blades
for 100 years they source their steel
from sweden
and they own the entire manufacturing
process from the r d
to the factory floor this allows them to
keep prices low
your eighth shave is as sharp as your
first
how is that possible i couldn't tell you
but they stand by it with a hundred
percent
quality control guarantee harry's is
available
wherever you're shopping at harry's
sharpest blades ever
at the big box drug and grocery stores
near you you just head on over
to the grooming aisle and by the way if
you like to shop online harry's has a
great offer for listeners to my show
go to get a harry's trial set
at harry's dot com slash knowles kwles
you get a five
blade razor featuring their newer
sharper blades a weighted handle foaming
shave gel
with aloe and the travel cover to
protect your blade when you're on the go
by the way you're going to like
you're going to like the price that you
have to pay all right you're not even
going to feel like you're
you're paying anything you're not you're
not going to feel that way go to
harrys.com
knowles redeem your trial offer
today so
senator hirono opens up the hearings
by asking judge amy coney barrett mother
of seven
catholic law professor appellate judge
if she has sexually harassed anybody and
the weird sex
questions only get weirder from there
democrats really do have an obsession
with sex here they have an obsession
with sex in the way that a fourth grader
has an obsession with sex
it's all they can think about they can't
raise their minds to higher things
so the next question from senator hirono
involves
same-sex marriage the redefinition of
marriage
which occurred in this country not
through the legislatures
not through some persuasion that that we
citizens
had amongst one another it's because
justice anthony kennedy decided to
redefine the fundamental political and
social institution
from the bench and maisie hirono is very
worried
that judge barrett does not agree with
justice kennedy's romantic poetry
this morning senator feinstein asked you
a question about the supreme court's
2015 decision
in obergefell the hodges the case in
which the court recognized
the constitutional right to same-sex
marriage and i was disappointed that you
wouldn't give a direct answer whether
you agreed
with the majority in that case or if you
instead agree with your mentor
justice scalia that no such right exists
in the constitution
obviously no such right exists in the
constitution does anybody seriously
believe
that james madison and alexander
hamilton
thought that what was going into that
constitution was the fundamental
redefinition of marriage for the first
time in human history
to not have something to do with sexual
difference to not have something to do
with the difference between men and
women
no nobody thinks that does anybody
seriously believe at the time the
constitution was ratified
the public meaning of that document was
that they were going to fundamentally
redefine
marriage as now no longer having
anything to do with sexual difference
no nobody seriously believes that does
anybody seriously believe
that in i don't know 1998
anybody believe the constitution
fundamentally redefined marriage how
about 2008
how about 2012 barack obama in 2012
still did not support gay marriage as
any sort of political right as any sort
of legislative issue
certainly not as any kind of
constitutional issue
at least in his public speech maybe he
was lying to us maybe in his mind he
really did support it
but at the very least i think we all
have to admit
nowhere does the constitution redefine
marriage so what happens
some robes lawyers on the supreme court
decided to take
that issue away from the people and our
self-government
and fundamentally redefine it which
follows perfectly in line
with justice kennedy's jurisprudence
when in planned parenthood v casey
he said that we have the right to define
our own conception
of existence we have the right to
redefine reality sure sure if you can
redefine reality
certainly you can redefine marriage
amy barrett handles these questions very
well smacks them down
obviously isn't going to comment on
individual cases
then senator hirono gets very very
upset because barrett is dealing with
the so well she's not taking the bait
but judge barrett used a very very
offensive term
do you know what that term was drum roll
sexual preference not once but twice
you use the term sexual preference
to describe those in the lgbtq community
and let me make clear sexual preference
is an offensive and outdated term
it is used by anti-lgbtq activists
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice
it is not sexual orientation is a key
part
of a person's identity that sexual
orientation
is both a normal expression of human
sexuality and
immutable was a key part
of the majority's opinion in a workflow
which by the way scalia did not agree
with
so if it is your view that sexual
orientation is merely a preference
as you noted then the lgbtq community
should be
rightly concerned whether you would
uphold their constitutional right to
marry
i knew that senator hirono was a hack
i didn't know that she was illiterate i
didn't know that she
doesn't understand the basic meaning of
words
there is nothing offensive about the
term preference
sexual preference is the most precise
term
that we can use to discuss these sexual
issues
that senator hirono is talking about and
there's nothing in it
that suggests that a preference is a
free choice preferences
can be innate preferences can come to us
from our very little childhood i have
had a preference for chocolate chip
cookies
over oatmeal raisin cookies for as long
as i can remember
i did not freely choose this preference
i did not wake up one day and say today
i am now going to choose to prefer
chocolate chip cookies how about ice
cream people have preferences do you
like chocolate ice cream or vanilla ice
cream
i assume you didn't choose that
preference you didn't sit and
intellectually decide okay i i'm gonna
be a vanilla guy
that's what i'm going to prefer no your
preferences are just that
actually this is the difference between
a preference and an opinion
often though the this is one of my pet
peeves but the left does this all the
time
they don't know what an opinion is
either so for instance they'll say
well these are the facts and everything
else is just your opinion
as if to say opinions are unreasonable
but opinions are not unreasonable
opinions are
statements of fact from our point of
view
so i form an opinion using my faculties
of reason
opinions can be true and some opinions
are false but we can debate opinion
because they're they're actually
referring to
objective fact there's a third option
which is
preference and you can't debate
preference
de gusti bus non desputan is a latin
phrase which means there's no arguing
over taste there's no accounting for
taste
i can't say to you excuse me johnny
you're completely mistaken
vanilla is much more delicious than
chocolate i can try to make some
arguments but ultimately
that question is coming down to a
question of taste and preference
there is talk about democrats reaching
they now they're begging they're trying
to redefine
this term which is perfectly innocuous
and perfectly precise
because they ain't got nothing unjudged
amy coney barrett so finally
once senator hirono stopped embarrassing
herself
at the senate dianne feinstein who
sometimes embarrasses herself but is at
least more impressive than
than macy hirono she got up and she
talked about the sexual question that
the democrats actually talk about
the ones that they actually want to to
know about which is not
sexual preferences it's not even the
redefinition of marriage
it is whether or not we're all going to
continue to pretend that the
constitution protects the right
to kill a baby dianne feinstein goes
directly after roe
do you agree with justice scalia's view
that roe
was wrongly decided so senator i do want
to be forthright and
answer every question so far as i can i
think
on that question i you know i'm going to
invoke justice kagan's description which
i think is
perfectly put when she was in her
confirmation hearing she said
that she was not going to grade
precedent or give it a thumbs up or a
thumbs down
and i think in an area where precedent
continues to be pressed and litigated
as is true of casey it would be
particularly
it would actually be wrong in a
violation of the canons for me to do
that as a sitting judge
so if if i express a view on a precedent
one way or another whether i say i love
it or i hate it
it signals to litigants then i might
tilt one way or another
in a pending case so
on something that is really a major
cause
with major effect on over half of the
population of this country who are women
after all
it's it's distressing not to get a
straight answer
so let me try again let me try again
since i have no idea what you just said
judge barrett
and if you could please tone down the
vocabulary here
to i don't know maybe a second or third
grade level maybe i could understand it
you almost feel bad for senator
feinstein listening to that exchange
because what amy barrett does is she
doesn't just say it's my right not to
say how i would rule on cases
which is fair enough she doesn't owe
dianne feinstein an answer on any case
but she actually goes further and she
says you know because these cases
are hotly contested i i can't tell you
which way i'm leaning on this
because if i were to do that then that
would signal to the litigants
some of my preferences and that would
actually change the course of justice
so she's making a really positive case
for why she can't answer these questions
the smarter senators decided just to
move on and and unfortunately they had
nothing to move on to
so you had these wacky scenes probably
the wackiest scene
yesterday was a democratic senator
sheldon whitehouse who with a name like
white house
i've always wondered why this guy wasn't
going to run for president
why wouldn't you run for president he's
been in the senate for a long time his
last name is white house
you're you're ready to go right but then
he opened his mouth yesterday during
these hearings and i realized why
probably not the most viable
presidential candidate
he went on and just tried out
some convoluted conspiracy theories
involving
dark money what is
the scheme here let me start with this
one
in all cases there's big anonymous money
behind various
lanes of activity one lane of activity
is through the conduit of the federalist
society
it's managed by a guy was managed by a
guy named leonard leo
and it's taken over the selection of
judicial nominees
how do we know that to be the case
because trump has said so
over and over again his white house
counsel said so
so we have an anonymously funded group
controlling judicial selection run by
this guy leonard leo
then in another lane we have again
anonymous funders
running through something called the
judicial crisis network
which is run by carrie severino and it's
doing pr
and campaign ads for republican
judicial nominees so by the end of this
presentation he's basically just
charlie day at the conspiracy board like
yeah and then this connects to that and
this connects to that and where's pepe
sylvia
there's no point that he ever gets to
there's no point
okay so there are conservative donors
who fund organizations and the
organizations
influence some of the judicial
conservative movement
okay you know the left has that too i
mean the left here
hey here's one molly hemingway posted
this yesterday this is from the
americans for public trust
here is sheldon whitehouse's dark money
okay so where's the dark money you've
got sheldon whitehouse over here
and then you've got arabella advisors
you got you got some money coming out of
there
then you got a guy named eric kessler
then you got the center for american
progress and you got the democracy
alliance you got george soros here he's
funding that
got tom steyer he's funding that then
all the money flows there okay
is that so does that mean sheldon
whitehouse is an illegitimate senator
no big politics attracts big money no
surprise there
i was speaking to senator cruz yesterday
we covered a little bit of this
on the verdict podcast he pointed out to
me that
of the 20 top political donors
14 of them give almost exclusively to
democrats
another three of them give to both sides
and then only three give mostly to
republicans
so if the democrats really want to open
this dark money door
fine by me most the vast majority of the
dark money is going
to democrats but the point here from
sheldon whitehouse
is not to expose anything about money
nothing he said implies
anything illegal whatsoever it's to
delegitimize the court it's to
delegitimize this nominee so that they
can try to stack it
later it's a cynical tactic but
overall probably the best card they had
to play and when they ran out of that
we could rely on corey spartacus booker
to cry tears of rage not about judge
barrett
but about president trump he he didn't
even try really
to go after judge barrett what you saw i
would say
as a general rule here is that these
guys were just
not prepared now you will want to be
prepared and there's no better time than
to do it right now
with ready-wise you should be prepared
with long-term nutritional food options
ready-wise has options such as emergency
meals freeze-dried fruits and vegetables
for convenient on-the-go nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities
ready weiss uses the finest ingredients
and latest food prep technology
to ensure optimal taste and freshness
every single recipe is crafted by a team
of chefs
to provide a nutritional meal during
critical times each meal is a
combination
of both dehydrated and freeze-dried
ingredients meals are packed into
durable
long-lasting pouches designed to keep
food fresh for up to 25 years you know
people
get ready wise foods to be prepared in
case of an emergency that's the point
but i will tell you
the taste is great we actually we got
some here at the office
and one of my producers i said what
happened to all the ready wise where is
that
where's it go and he was eating it for
lunch every day because they actually
taste
very very good and you get the added
benefit then of them having a shelf life
of 25 years so you will be prepared in
these uncertain times this week my
listeners
get free shipping at readywise.com when
entering knowles cnwles at checkout or
by calling 855-453-2945
there is a 90-day no questions asked
return policy
no risk taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family prepared that
is r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e-com promo code
knowles
to get free shipping
cory booker spartacus was not prepared
with any any dirt on judge barrett so he
went straight at trump specifically
he asked judge barrett about president
trump's refusal
to say that he would peacefully transfer
power
if he loses the election i appreciate
what you've said about respecting our
founding fathers about the originalism
it's remarkable that we're at a place
right now that this is becoming a
question
and a topic but i'm asking you in light
of our founding fathers
and loud of our traditions in light that
everyone who serves in that office has
sworn an oath
where they quote swear to preserve and
protect and defend the constitution of
the united states
i'm just asking you should a president
commit themselves
like our founding fathers i think have a
clear intention
like the grace that george washington
showed
to the peaceful transfer of power is
that something that presidents
should be able to do do you think that
the president has the power to pardon
himself
for any past or future crimes he
he may have committed against the united
states of america well senator booker
that would be a legal question that
would be a constitutional question and
so
in keeping with my obligation not to
give hints previews or forecasts of how
i would resolve the case that's not one
that i can answer
well i i think i agree with you that it
is an issue right now something i never
thought would be an issue before
but it is an issue uh yeah i agree with
you judge barrett yeah isn't trump
terrible
because he won't say that he'll
peacefully transfer power you know trump
the guy who won in 2016 and then we
refused
to give up power and you know then he
was president and we the left tried to
overthrow his presidency and we're
continuing to do that
you know you know that guy why won't he
you know the guy
running against democrats our party uh
which just said that joe biden should
not concede under any circumstances that
was that was hillary clinton the
previous democrat presidential nominee
you know that guy yeah can you believe
he won't transfer power that's stupid
question trump should never answer that
question
don't get the minute you accept the
premise of that question
you've already lost the idea that you
might not peacefully transfer power
to the left which has spent the last
nine months burning the country to the
ground
so once he moves past that stupid hack
talking point then he moves to another
stupid hack talking point
and asks judge barrett to condemn white
supremacy
i'm going to ask you some questions that
if you had told me five years ago
that would be questions asked at a
supreme court nomination hearing
i would have thought they wouldn't be
possible but unfortunately
i think they're necessary to ask you and
i hope that you'll give me direct
answers the first one um
you've already spoken towards issues of
racism and how you deplore it
but i want to just ask you very simply i
imagine you'll give me a very short
resolute answer
um but you condemn white supremacy
correct
yes thank you i'm glad to see
that you said that i wish our president
uh
would say that so resolutely
unequivocally as well but we are at a
time
that americans are literally fearful
because their president
cannot do that in the resolute manner in
which you did i'm
i'm sorry that that question had to even
be asked at this time i'm sorry i don't
want it to be asked but it has to be
asked it has to be
judge barrett do you condemn the tooth
fairy uh yes
yes senator booker okay judge barrett i
have to ask this because this is such a
real live issue
not a completely fake contrived issue do
you do you condemn the easter bunny
sure senator booker i condemn the easter
okay i have to i have to ask you that
i didn't know what your answer would be
judge barrett who has two black kids
that you adopted from haiti
i didn't know your answer because trump
trump
won't condemn that super real thing
that thing that's totally real that
millions of people support you know
white supremacy you know that thing
that's totally real he just won't
he won't condemn it right mr president
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are
criminals and thugs including the kkk
neo-nazis white supremacists and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything
we hold dear as americans and you had
people
and i'm not talking about the neo-nazis
and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned totally
we are a nation
founded on the truth that all of us
are created equal we are equal in the
eyes of
our creator we are equal under the law
and we are equal under our constitution
those who spread violence in the name of
bigotry
strike at the very core of america how
many times do i have to reject
i've rejected david duke rejected david
duke
i've rejected the kkk the ku klux klan
from the time i'm five years old i
rejected them now
i have been asked this question so many
times i have rejected it so many times
i just wish he would give an answer i
just wish he could just tell us
what do you think about white supremacy
you know
in this white supremacist country that
you know that real thing you know what
do you
so that's all they've got they just make
up a bunch of nonsense and then
uh barrett absolutely of course smacked
it down she smacked it down
by the way without notes this was maybe
the highlight of her performance at
yesterday's hearing she did it without
notes you are going to want to take
notes however
at this wonderful conference that is
coming up one
week from today where the daily wire god
king
jeremy boring will be presenting
alongside a team
of world-renowned business experts at
expert ownership live two-day virtual
conference
about leading through crisis the
conference features a lineup of speakers
like leadership author john maxwell
the founders of duck commander in
otterbox the benham brothers many others
who can relate
to what entrepreneurs and leaders are
going through right now they will share
stories about their own businesses and
startup journeys
the tough times that necessarily come
with any company even here at daily wire
even actually when the business was
doing well in a certain sense
there are these huge issues that can
come up that that have
threatened a lot of businesses including
our own this conference is one of those
investments
that your business will be thanking you
for in the long run so visit
expertownershiplive.comwles
register for 197. buy a second ticket
for a friend
for 50 off and you come on look you'll
get to see jeremy which actually maybe
i don't know if that's a selling point
or if that's but look he's got a lot of
wisdom
expert ownership dot com i'm sorry
expert ownership live dot com
slash knowles buy one ticket for 197
dollars
get another one for 50 off expert
ownership live dot com
slash knowles judge barrett knocks it
all down
and does it without any notes a
wonderful moment that was teed up by
texas senator
john cornyn you know most of us have
multiple notebooks and notes and books
and things like that
in front of us can you hold up what
you've been referring to and answering
our questions
is there anything on it uh that
letterhead that says united states
senate
that's imper that's impressive holds up
a page from my own book my own book
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide
i think that's what that blank page was
speaking of which by the way this is
just a little personal side note
i am selling so many copies of this
blank book reasons to vote for democrats
a comprehensive guide which president
trump called a great book for your
reading enjoyment
i am selling so many copies right now
that i i mention it not just to tell you
how happy i am and to thank you for
buying the copies
but also to tell you i consider this
like a secret poll of the election the
fact that all these people are buying
this joke on democrats
it reminds me of some of these other
kind of more hidden poll numbers right
everyone says oh we all hate trump and
yet 56 percent of americans according to
gallup say they're better off than they
were
four years ago all these little little
numbers especially in swing states
are seem to be very very nice for the
president but in any case judge barrett
wherever she got her blank sheet of
paper she held it up
you have senators here the democratic
senators
who could not even ask a question
without notes their heads were buried in
their paper cory booker was reading from
the paper and he still
messed up his delivery you have a
democratic presidential nominee
who can't remember his own name and
we'll get to some of his
stumbles on the campaign trail in just a
second can't remember much of anything
and then you have our judicial nominee
judge barrett who goes
12 hours yesterday
without any notes the left
the democrats they don't have a chance
against that and so things are looking
very good you don't want to
count your chickens before they hatch
but
right now it's looking very good for
judge barrett we'll get more hearings
today we do have a lot to get to though
because actually i felt the best
democratic arguments
or at least the most plausible they
weren't that plausible
came from one of their presidential
candidates who dropped out
who's not even in the senate but he
should be because he's much more
impressive than all those other guys
we will get to him in one second if you
haven't already heard though daily wires
old glory
daily wire baseball bat is back this is
our limited edition handcrafted custom
painted baseball bat
emblazoned with the dw logo since we
relaunched this on monday they are
almost all sold out again the first time
we did it sold out in 48 hours and it
was only available
to all access in that case today is the
last day they will be available i don't
even know if they're still available
right now but you can
you can try to get yours okay try to get
get your number in
uh text the keyword baseball
b-a-s-e-b-a-l-l
to eight three four zero zero that's
eighty three thousand four hundred
eight three four zero to purchase your
bat today we'll be right back with a lot
more
the closest thing to convincing
opposition i i saw yesterday against
barrett
came from someone who wasn't even in the
room this was pete buddha judge
who the left the left thinks he's making
good arguments because he says things in
a calm way
and he's sort of polished and has some
nice academic credentials
so they they think that the arguments
he's making are sound they're not but
they
they kind of have the sound of soundness
and so
they're calling him slayerpete on
twitter it's it's kind of lame
it's not going to stick so mayor pete
alfred
newman that was the nickname that trump
gave him he goes on msnbc
and makes an argument against not just
barrett but against her judicial
philosophy
of originalism this is what nominees do
they
they write the the most seemingly
unobjectionable
dry stuff but really what i see in there
is judicial a pathway to judicial
activism cloaked
in judicial humility at the end of the
day
rights in this country have been
expanded because
courts have understood what the true
meaning of the letter of the law and the
spirit of the constitution
is and that is not about time traveling
yourself back to the 18th century
and subjecting yourself to the same
prejudices and limitations
as the people who write these words the
constitution is a living document
because the english language
is a living language and you need to
have some
readiness to understand that in order to
serve on the court in a way that's
actually going to make life
better so nothing he just said is true
and everything is extraordinarily
radical
but because he's saying it in a calm way
it seems almost plausible he contradicts
himself immediately right he says
look what i see here judge barrett
is talking about how she just wants to
read the text by what the words actually
mean
and what they were understood to mean it
ratification that's judicial activism
okay because for decades now the court
has been expanding rights
based on how they know the truth
and the spirit of the constitution so
some judge
writing in 2015 knows better
than what the constitution says then the
people who wrote the constitution and
the people who were alive at the time of
ratification who wrote about the
constitution
well that's madness how how on earth
could you make that argument well he
says because
it's a living breathing document now it
just is a simple matter it is not living
it's dead
it's on dead paper it's on dead trees
with dead ink
and it's not breathing it's paper and
paper doesn't breathe
so it's not a living breathing document
he says but the meaning of it changes
as the english language changes so for
instance
let's say that there's a law
against murder you cannot commit murder
and then the word murder because
language changes over time
comes to mean not killing somebody
intentionally
but eating chocolate ice cream that's
just the new i don't know it's kind of a
weird way language evolved but
now for some reason murder means eating
chocolate ice cream does that mean that
it is illegal for me to eat chocolate
ice cream
of course not could you imagine the
chaos that our laws would be subjected
to that our entire system of government
would be subjected to
if we had to interpret statutes by what
words mean at any given time by the way
who's supposed to
define how the words mean as they are
changing
the reason we have linguistic
prescription
namely saying you should use you should
use words
as they are defined is because if you
have a linguistic description
meaning you should use words as whatever
the way kind of people are using them
now
people use words differently now the the
the very nature of language changing
means that
at the moment right now as as the
meaning is somewhat unclear
we can't arrive at a at a specific
meaning
which is buddha judge's point because
what he really wants to do is just
empower judges to impose their will on
the language
p buddha judge who pretends to be a
moderate his father
was in a radical academic he was the
president of the international grommashi
society antonio gramsci
is the first self-described cultural
marxist
he was the leader of the italian
communist party and he wrote
very pretty interesting texts actually
about how
marx got certain things wrong and we
need to apply the marxist revolutionary
concepts to the culture
to take over institutions and wage a war
of position rather than a war of
maneuver this would later be interpreted
by the radicals of the 60s as the long
march
through the institutions basically
melding the language of mao and the
language of gramsci
buddha judge's dad was such an admirer
of gramsci that he was a co-founder and
president of the international gramsci
society okay this guy is coming from a
very radical intellectual perspective
which comes down to and gramsci by the
way is is one of the major influences on
what we now call political correctness
well what buddha judge is talking about
is political correctness right he's just
saying yeah we're going to redefine
words
to mean whatever we want them to mean
and then however we define them
conveniently that's what we're going to
read into the constitution
he then tries to defend this by by
citing
thomas jefferson it was actually thomas
jefferson himself
who said that uh we might as well ask a
man to still wear the coat which fitted
him when he was a boy
as expect future generations to live
under what he called
the regime of their barbarous ancestors
uh so even the founders
that uh uh the the that these kind of
dead hand originalists claim fidelity to
understood better than their ideological
descendants uh today's judicial
uh so-called conservatives the
importance of keeping with the times
and we deserve judges and justices who
understand that
what thomas jefferson was referring to
you don't need a crystal ball you can
just read the rest of his writing what
he's referring to
is not how future generations should
redefine
basic language and usurp the power of
the people to define how they're going
to live
he's talking about the amendment process
nobody says we should live under exactly
the same constitution that they had
in the 18th century they're they're
saying yeah we should change it with the
times even
antonin scalia said he wished it were
even easier to change the constitution
but there is a process
called the amendment process but buddha
judge knows his radical ideas would
never make it through the amendment
process
so instead he just wants to steal power
even buddha jed who's
i guess the most articulate of the
democratic players right now who's
coming out
nothing he's offering nothing he's
offering just spurious
ridiculous arguments so barrett did very
well we're going to hear more from her
today
the way you know that this is not going
very well for democrats
is that even the mainstream media
are trying to change course here nancy
pelosi was on talking to wolf blitzer on
cnn
and you know cnn just carries water for
democrats all the time
but on this issue of of the
current process wolf blitzer actually
cut her off
and nancy pelosi became so enraged she
accused them of shilling for the
republicans
even members of i haven't said that but
but even members of your own caucus
even members of your own caucus madam
speaker uh
want to accept this deal one point eight
trillion dollars congressman rowe conor
yeah
exactly well let me just let me just
quote a man you know well
i assume you admire him he's a democrat
and he just said this he said people in
need can't wait
until february 1.8 trillion dollars
is significant and more than twice the
obama stimulus
make a deal put the ball in mcconnell
court so what do you say to ro connor
what i say to you is i don't know why
you're always an apologist
and many of your colleagues apologize
for the republican position
rolcana that's nice that isn't what
we're going to do and nobody's waiting
till february
cnn they're apologists for the
republican position how can nancy pelosi
say that with a straight face
not even fox is apologizing and
defending republican positions anymore
much less cnn are you kidding me
are you kidding me how does she say that
because
occasionally they push back on democrats
and the democrats are not used to that
the thing you have to remember though is
that wolf blitzer and nancy pelosi want
the same thing they want more government
power and they want to spend
more and more money and they want
democrats to win elections
they want the same goals
but they're having a disagreement over
tactics when the media and the left
disagree
it's never over the end goal when the
media and conservatives disagree
it's over the goals it's over the vision
of the country it's over the politics
but the political system rather when the
media and the left
elected democrats are disagreeing
because obviously the media are the left
but when the media
elected democrats are disagreeing it's
over tactics not politics
pelosi is saying i'm going to play
hardball with trump and maybe we don't
get a deal on kovid
wolf blitz are saying damn it you need a
deal on kovid because we're losing this
election
so come on nancy get your act together
it's like a little spat between lovers
you know
they do want the same thing in the end
but there is disagreement now on the
left
about how they go about that they've got
no answer
joe biden was asked about that gallup
poll i referred to earlier at 56 percent
of americans
say they're better off today than they
were four years ago he was asked
about what he would say to people who
feel that way he
not not only did he not have an answer
it wasn't just that
he had the worst answer possible gallup
reported
last week 50 56 of americans said that
they were better off today
than they were four years ago would have
been under the obama binding
administration
so why should people who feel that they
are better off today
under the trump administration vote for
you well if they think that they
probably shouldn't
i'm donald trump and i approve this
message
i don't think that's an actual trump
campaign i think someone just clipped
that together on the internet but it
could be i think trump should run that
ad
what do you say to people who say
they're better off under trump even with
a pandemic even with an economic
collapse they're better off under trump
than they were under you
as well i got nothing to say to them i
guess they shouldn't vote for me
wrong answer i mean it's the correct
answer it's the true answer but
politically it's
incorrect politically it's not
advantageous compare that guy
to president trump who is now he's
feeling better than ever
he goes to a rally in pennsylvania he
says he's feeling so good
he's feeling so safe from the virus he
wants to kiss everybody
and i could have stayed in the basement
of the white house or maybe the top
floor of the white house i could have
done that but i'm the president of the
united states i can't do that
i got to get out and i have to meet
people and i have to see people
and i know it's risky to do that but you
have to do what you have to do you know
i'm the president i can't sit in the
basement and say let's wait this thing
out
i'm not going to do that and now i'm
immune they tell me i'm immune i could
come down and start kissing everybody
i'll kiss every guy man and woman man
and woman look at that guy how handsome
he is
i'll kiss him not not with a lot of
enjoyment but that's okay
i'll kiss them all the men and the women
even the men it won't be my favorite
you got to remember and we always forget
it about this guy because he's
he's pretty smooth about it this is a
showman this guy
is a comedian i mean he is a top tier
comedian
he's a top tier hollywood guy and has
been for 30 years
and i'm glad he's going out there and
doing rallies he should be doing a whole
lot more rallies that is where he is
thriving
democrats are trying to cook the debates
that's the right thing compare that
compare that guy on his feet
there was a video going around of trump
dancing the ymca
on on uh you know one of these platforms
one of these rally stages
there's no need to be unhappy he's just
he's feeling good he's feeling healthy
compare that to joe who hasn't even had
the coronavirus
he can't remember anything you may
remember
i got in trouble when we were running
against the senator who was a mormon
the governor okay and i took him on no
he is a senator
he was a governor i like that joe biden
starts this up you may remember
uh no you you may remember i hope you
remember because i don't remember what
were we talking about where am i
it's joe biden that's joe biden without
coronavirus
donald trump with coronavirus much more
vigorous than joe biden without
coronavirus
speaking by the way of of uh
senator romney i mean biden has you've
seen these
he's had so many of these moments he
just recently again
said that he's a proud democrat running
for the senate you know he doesn't even
remember what office he's running for
very very sad and in the midst of this
speaking of mitt romney you have the
answer to the question that nobody was
asking
romney says here are my thoughts on
the political situation because it's one
of these stupid awful
infographics because i've stayed quiet
with the approach of the election but
i'm troubled by our politics
as it has moved away from spirited
debate to a vile vituperative
hate-filled morass
that is unbecoming of any free nation
let alone the birthplace of modern
democracy
the president calls the democratic vice
presidential candidate
a monster he repeatedly labels the
speaker of the house crazy
he calls for the justice department to
put the prior president in jail
he attacks they got blah blah blah blah
blah then
he says does he ever get to the
democrats here
he does oh yes he says pelosi tears up
the president's state of the union
speech on national television
keith olbermann calls the president a
terrorist media on the left and right
amplify it all and and you know it's so
awful he even he gives the democrats
another best he says democrats launch
blistering attacks of their own
though their presidential nominee
refuses to stoop as low
as others biden he's a good guy vote for
biden is what he's really saying
these attacks are terrible they're
dangerous it's time to lower the heat
this guy is insufferable mitt romney he
thinks
that whining makes him virtuous
he thinks that sanctimony
makes him virtuous he thinks that
self-righteousness
makes him righteous
it doesn't this is pure cowardice
that's that's what we've got from romney
you know i voted for the guy in the
general in 2012
but in my defense i worked for two of
his uh
primary opponents i always knew romney
was like this
and and he's proving it right this is
pure cowardice
because what romney's saying is i'm a
republican but not one of those
republicans
what romney's saying is i hate the
political reality fine i think a lot of
us
hate the political reality or at least
we would prefer a different political
reality yeah i think all of us would
and he says and i'm just i'm so much
better than our politics i'm so much
better than this
i don't want to have to do this i don't
have to vote for trump he's mean
buddy there is nothing
nice and kind and virtuous about
divorcing yourself from reality and
choosing to live in fantasy
nothing at all this is where we are that
politics happens in reality it doesn't
happen in fantasy
doesn't happen in ideological manifestos
it doesn't happen
in mitt romney's pruned and gardened
wonderful walled off life it happens in
reality if you want to do anything
for us in politics you have to do it in
reality
and these thinly veiled
sort of subtle endorsements of joe biden
who would empower all of these awful
people
is is a is a cowardly low
sort of thing to do and even if even if
he would deny that even if he says no
i'm not
subtly endorsing biden which i think he
is but even if he weren't
to throw up your hands and say oh it's
all awful we've both got problems we
don't this is something that has been
pushed by the left
the left has degraded our language the
left has degraded our politics the left
has degraded our supreme court
nomination process
the left has degraded our presidential
elections by refusing to accept the
results
in 2000 in 2016 in 2017 in 2018 when
they tried to launch a coup d'etat
not successfully thankfully they have
done
this and what romney wants to say is oh
we're both bad aren't we yeah i'm a good
guy don't you like me
pathetic absolutely pathetic so it is an
embarrassment that that man is in the
u.s senate
it would be so much better if he were
not in the u.s senate
and if he gave that seat up to a
conservative who has courage
which is a virtue and it's the
prerequisite for all of the other
virtues i've got to get to gay cookies
before we go
i have to i want to end where we began
on democrats weird sex obsession
oreos beginning october 9th
are shipping out rainbow colored cookies
colored cream cookies that are given
away to the first 10 000 people
to share on social media their idea of
allyship allyship is some newfangled
word
that refers to endorsing the sexual
revolution endorsing the left's view on
sex
specifically they say it's with regard
it used to be with regard to
homosexuality now it's obviously
expanded much more than that to the lgbt
which is kind of the t undermines the g
right because the transgender undermines
the arguments for same same-sex
attraction or the homosexual orientation
because the t
undermines your gender so you know just
to put it in simple terms
if you're a gay guy and you say oh i
can't change this i was born this way
and then you got the transgender
movement comes along and says of course
you can change your gender so then the
gay guy
makes himself cosmetically look like a
woman i guess he's no longer a gay guy
so i guess he did change his sexual
orientation
or he didn't change his gender or
gender is a silly concept pushed by the
left and really there's biological sex
which obviously you can't change
either way this is an ideology this is
not
a sexual preference or a sexual
orientation or whatever words you want
to use
this is left-wing ideology
and it's even come into our cookies
cookies
how did we get here the the democrat
obsession with sex the left's obsession
with sex
it's not about guys who are sexually
attracted to other guys
or gals who are sexually attracted to
other gals or people who are confused
about their sex or have some kind of
psychological issue not about that at
all not about that at all it is about
control it derives from a simple phrase
that the feminist left gave us in the 19
late 1960s early 1970s
the personal is the political
the personal is the political that
basically politics has to come down
to every thing in our society has to
enter into the bedroom
has to enter into the local community
has to enter into our sneakers has to
enter into our food
has to enter into our chicken sandwiches
has to enter into our cookies
everything has to be political but there
is a flip side to this which is
as everything becomes political the only
thing that gets de-politicized
is politics no longer are we permitted
to have disagreements over
the way our constitution should be
enforced in our country
and this and how the systems that the
constitution set up
sets up i'll be more precise we'll make
the laws for us we're not allowed to
have those discussions anymore we're not
allowed to have those debates
now we have to just pretend that the
constitution means whatever people just
says it means or whatever anthony
kennedy says it means or whatever ruth
ginsburg says it means
but but interestingly not what amy
barrett says it means
politicizing everything is a distraction
and an unmooring from any kind of
traditional sense of our society
so that we will be distracted look away
and in the meantime our actual political
questions
over eternal questions justice equality
liberty
all these things that we debate and we
try to figure out how they should be
enacted in our society those are taken
away from us
and those are now being made by the very
ideologues who are distracting us with
bread
and circuses and we saw a circus
yesterday
on capitol hill bread and circuses
and gay cookies all all
to turn us away from the real political
decisions
that are being made far far away from
the free choice of we the people
that's our show i'm michael nolsas the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wodowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen